la sécurité n'a pas de prix
alors depuis ta langue fait des blagues
en scred mais je pleure devenue malade
semaine bref alors ça parce que c'est
mon copain km ou 6 beaudet a les mots
bouder j'étais super content de te voir
ah bah moi aussi mais j'en ai marre de
tes rires son minitel qui passent dans
la rue
bon il marche et il a mal à la main ils
croisent un pote à lui repris sa vie
qu'est ce que tu as dit j'ai mal d'aimer
tamalous et j'ai mal aux pieds
mais pourquoi tu as mal aux pieds dit ma
femme ce matin elle s'est barrée avec le
banquier et moi j'aime à gérer mais d'un
grand mais qui savent avec ton pied tout
ça et je te dis c'est mal et demi j'ai
compris je table mais qu'est ce qui
t'arrive et 10g main parce que si cet
après midi
mon fils il est parti à la mairie il a
demandé à ce qu'ils soient qu'ils sont
de moulis vraie famille veut plus le
choix son père et moi j'ai ma cavale qui
savoir plus dit j'ai mal je te dis mais
pourquoi tu as mal aidé parce que mon
chien aussi sebaa et baba
non content que tu as mal mais pourquoi
tu as mal aux pieds dit j'ai mal aux
pieds
parce que ce matin j'ai regardé mon
compte bancaire
j'ai plus d'argent on comprendre tu
avales luc hees a white et pied et dj
malo clipesque howett
c'est du 42 et ça c'est du 36 et moi
j'aimais et 10 mai et pour rattacher pas
du 40 2 elijah j'ai pas du 42 parce que
le congrès a vu mes chaussures
c'est le seul moment où je kiffe dans ma
vie
tous